колодязь з дитячою пісочницею міняє наш
кіну парту типу джиної тир 1 клас
все в річкових став ваш комп з потом
найвища для porsche класних це їх
батьки
його складу летучі і в 4 2012 рі крик
експериментальне міністерство про святі
волосся лоб троянда право gillet нових
державних стандартів підіб'ють кови і
зонального почту
якщо прошу ось зона копошився трудове
будні в інноваціях чітко прописано моя
буде забезпечена доступність
змінити кудашкіна етапи чіткого і
заодно з видами цими словами перехитрить
ти так що жити від дорослого за парту та
травня буде чинним і планомірним
садочку діти пачино ловити англійську
мову і чому не приходило до школи та
англійському захоплення про взялася
цілий ре вон і почитав і читай з
іншого класу а зараз ми в першому
продовжимо цьому у нас не травня 1
і ми мого чоловіка всі наші знання з
потрібного типу пам'ятаю от і одразу
англійській мові ттп
обов'язково урок для всіх пишечки всього
вимагає тримаючи мені стандарти
чого артузова то живіт і дену dokumu
віце іноземну нову батьківщину 1
голос ну так мотивація збиті до 10
років на і берс приємно вийде для
закладання базових знань давали
психологи я ще заняття проводяться в
ігровій формі дітям відео вище задумав
це цікаве і тому що ми йдемо
його ти трошки крокуємо і це все-таки
потрібен іноземна мова дітям до вивчаємо
і багато хто ходить на додаткові курси
з вивчення тобто це все на ігровому
рівні співаємо пісеньки вже якісь говоримо
якісь фразочки це вже цікаво
ще момент безодню добра за зводиться до
водяться у вигляді бі манки
а х а слідом за англійською нові
малява подавати їм комп'ютер другом
класу дітей обов'язково читати азан
інформатики доторкнутися не лучник
все-таки давати її обама лаяв
дід хотіла, бо там були різні
наукові ігри були цікаві завдання з
ньому life шукаєш і знай ти на кафедрі
ще прахова а там можна написати з того
він тобі і надати далі
троси сволочей сьогодні плити наповнено
блоджетт і я знання віку в анал три бою
на уроках можна швидкістю за 100 суботи
вже ті будинки розповімо на рівні
користування клавіатурі та мишці
все-таки розкажуть докладно що з чого
складається і пізнання б набагато більше
чим у батька не на рівні користувача
може якось знайде собі в цьому
покликання в майбутньому стане великим
програмістом де ти вже на приклад
п'ятому вухатому 7 клас охорони починають
суккота реферати сука тут вже багатою
інформації для своєї роботи для своїх
шкільних скажемо і так звати вони в
інтернеті а
інформатикою до кількох з 9 класу з
абсолютно неправильна до чого не будучи
ти школа ванни навчаться тут всього на
осторонь і потім ситуацію доводьте
виправляти та витримані стандарти
вимагаєте нового підходу до самої
початкової програми that the їй та
насиченості закри emotiv epoc виглядом а
ще екологічну з прямого є
природознавство надається знаш
напиши поважає 1 дэна на ти ж не в душі
мало іопа нувот і все махає гай
знайшли нині природою cyma дружини можливо
2-го 12 доларів ми не приймаю за означає
і рахунок ще я зараз з постригаєм
форми
методи ніч вони режим дня режим три дні
це до спилка ваня
набити сонячний вигляд кабінеті все пік
порядку ванна
щоб комфортно було маленькому
школярів і ми на ми каємося за б спекти
ти ж праведнику мовляв для наших
готова або травма вати психіку дитини
початкова школа webmin його таке поняття
я копії ваня бала ми тут у пріоритеті
гарні слова в цій школі перші два
класу оцінка вербально то вважайте тим
кажуть там добре чудово розумничка
оцінки не ставлять тому що оцінки але
напевно, це велика психологічна
навантаження для дитини при тому коли
дитина приходить додому і щоденник з
оцінками ось як у нас було до коли ми
були маленькі дивляться батьки все-таки
це велика відповідальність, а так він
припадає школи та гинули каже та у
мене все було чудово мене
похвалили
існують контрольну роботу батьки
за бажання протестувати дитиною
дивитися як він вчиться йому подивитися
на ці контрольної роботи дуже
цікаво з англійської мови у них там
і своя вербальна система оцінок і вони
там ну як це можна сказати напевно
нагороджують діти предметами тобто це
зірочки там приклеюються якісь
квіточки тих не діткам, які добре
вчаться у дотримання 100 орендований
пептидів нормально вихідному процесі
обов'язково витриманих стандартний
йти їй ви могли травня до прямого тис orgy
тільки вистій абелю дощ і
50 викладок важливі висоту індивідуальної
п'яти до шкірні біттери на заняттям
приходили до нас герої на канал приходив
незнайка сова 40
і чаклун він нам і зачарованому приклади
а ми навіть не їх і були вирішувати так
цікаво дуже цікаво було на
математики там ці ось там дуже складні
задачі нам їхньому захисті не ниєш вирішуємо і
мені дуже цікаво займатися тому
що це розважає
для того б початкова школа настала для
дітей мене під сильним тя гарем руку
розсовувати здоров'язберігаючий
технології які ж епізоди поспішати
на лижню гігієнічнішу мову оптимальну
організацію порушено духовний процес
до фізичної активності вже не
засмоктуванні підірве брега че з
технологією зменшився в тумо наукові
проти вас уроки в корені шкірних.
людина не проводиш фізкульт паузи
гімнастику для вух у нашому заході
режимі дня їжі нами що належить зв'яжем
а пошесть якщо іншу руку проти м40
хвалили
так як школа повного дня гіти запит
patch тижневий сном триц три разовим на
гарячому харчевому їм відлік
закладу лиса human action великий
процес
інформацію вали кабінету володів цим
візором та комп'ютером та інтерактивними
дошками магнітофона на своїх уроках
великому класти і я моя дружина всіх уроках
на кущові мультимедійні презентації та
від показуючи доз віце їжу ж ефективним
мультимедійна презентація поїду долі
динаміку звуку зображення диво я збоку
за дієти
петелька організ прийняти обітницю і
і рухається ах ти не джерело на уроках
краще за свій ці початкові матеріали
пишіть об'єм до кам'яних робіт на
каліцтві
а для бочки багато про послуги можна весь
вид винні заняття своє та baby-g
якщо батьки мали можливість
присутня за середами, то фізично вона
існувала це парта в кінці класи
можна було присутній на уроках
дивитися як іде урок
але мабуть ну як особисто для мене це
було не для того, щоб там оцінити
роботу вчителя подивитися як дитина
адаптується до школи як він дотримується
школі дисципліну цікаво йому не
цікаво це дуже зручно для батьків
це дуже зручно батьки перш за все
вони дивляться на адаптацію дитини на школі
це дуже важливо першому класі коли він
перебуває у стресовому стані
на рази обласна влада засікла
профільне управління сто рив і optima
не розумом і для переходу підкови та почту
на ноги та державні стандарти проводяться
тренінги цей об'єкт монета семінари для
у мешканці порядкових класів протеаз
витян і не замінюється на досягнутому уа
лаються далі батіль кайр погіршити
можна досі ти прогресу то біля дошки
наливали